there are way more intellectual black
democrats you could have sat down with
it you
you chose an illiterate rapper because
that's what she is she's illiterate
yeah that's candace owens throwing some
major shade at cardi b
following the rapper's chat with
presidential candidate joe biden
and cardi she's not having it oh
snappity-snap snap
it all started on sunday when candace
tweeted this clip of herself on the ben
shapiro show
accusing both the former vice president
and bernie sanders of pandering to black
people by conducting
interviews with cardi it is demeaning it
is pandering it is ridiculous okay
and she asks pointedly ridiculous
questions i want lower taxes but i want
universal health care for all she had no
idea what she was doing and yet both
bernie sanders and joe biden made the
time to sit with her because they
believe black people are stupid
and black people that thought yay that's
a win no it's not a win yeah
she didn't sugarcoat it it is one of the
biggest insults
and cardi who has opened up before about
english not being her first language
fired back on twitter writing in part
quote
i don't want to argue with you candace i
really don't have the time i honestly
just feel sorry for you
but that's not all cardi had to say to
the conservative commentator
not even close quote you are encouraging
millions to vote for a man who laugh
every time a black man gets killed by a
cop
and tell millions of americans to drink
bleach trump didn't even have you
talking at the republican convention
he thinks you're dumb oh yes honey
candace responded claiming that she
turned down making an appearance at the
republican national convention
i get tired of your commenters and your
fans saying
oh she's cloud chasing i'd be cloud
chasing if i was challenging you to a
rap battle i'm not doing that you're in
my area
you're in politics you're embarrassed
because you realize you know nothing
about
anything when you're on twitter candace
did an eight-minute long igtv in
response to cardi on sunday
you're only upset because people are
telling you on twitter that you got
dragged
because you did get dragged because you
aren't educated when it comes to
politics candace also mocked cardi for
asking biden about lowering taxes while
also wanting free universal health care
cardi clarified in a later tweet that
she wants her taxes to go to causes she
cares about
like education and that's when cardi
took the feud to instagram live
why wouldn't joe biden sit down with me
cardi b
i have millions of followers
and i pay millions in texas
i'm heard all around the world
so just like i can make people pop their
and have a good time and make them feel
like a bad [ __ ] i could also encourage
millions of followers to go vote
and i don't know what black men broke
your heart that you hate your kind
so much once the dust seemingly settled
cardi reflected on the feud and tweeted
that she hates
arguing with people adding that she
didn't even really know how they started
fighting in the first place
as for candice she felt like she walked
away from the beef
victorious quote she is still tweeting
about me
i broke cardi b of course all this comes
after cardi spoke to the 77 year old
politician in august
as a part of her feature in elle
magazine's september issue
we may be related to something cardi b
and joey
cardi didn't hold back sharing the
issues that are important to her
and racism always have have existed but
i feel like right now
there's just a lot of tension and
we need somebody to clean that i'm just
so tired of it